and welcome to Hannity all right tonight
we are only 63 days away from the
all-important midterm elections there
are dozens of very close very critical
races nothing you should take for
granted but the stakes say could not be
higher and straight ahead we're going to
lay out exactly what is at stake for
every American and in the coming days
and weeks we will monitor all the key
matchups all across the country
including Pennsylvania where the
Socialist Bernie loving trust fund brat
who never worked a day in his life in a
hoodie John fetterman he is now refusing
to debate his opponent world-renowned
surgeon washing an outsider Dr mehmon Oz
now early voting in Pennsylvania it
starts in two weeks the people in the
Commonwealth of Pennsylvania they need
answers to all of his insane radical
positions that are truly to the left of
Bernie Sanders and after his
catastrophic stroke we wish him the best
health it does not appear that fetterman
is capable of debating much less serving
as a U.S senator we have all those
details coming up tonight plus the
political weapon weaponization of our
justice system has never been more
apparent in a moment we're going to
bring you shocking New Revelations about
the apparent Hunter Biden cover-up along
with the very latest on The doj's Witch
Hunt against Donald Trump but first the
Democrats want the upcoming election
they want this to be about anything
other than their disastrous failed
record they now want to shift the
Public's attention to all things Donald
Trump are you or have you ever been a
supporter of Donald J Trump if so
President Biden he has a message for you
because according to Joe well so-called
Maga Republicans you are a threat to
democracy we're all enemies of the state
a pretty disgusting blatant focus group
tested effort and slogan to distract you
the American people for what our
catastrophic policies and a horrific
agenda and he's doing it just in time
for the midterms It Is by Design not
unlike for example Barack Obama uh
bitter people clinging to their God Guns
Bibles and religion or Hillary Rodham
Clinton irredeemable deplorable uh
comment or Peter strzok's oh Trump
supporting smelly Walmart shoppers you
know why uh why are the Democrats doing
this ask yourself they can't run on
their 40-year high of inflation that
they caused the recession that they
caused the looming housing crisis all of
which they caused gas prices now double
what they were under Donald Trump
fentanyl record amounts of opioids
crossing our border they cause they're
allowing violent crime in small towns
and big cities all across the country
open borders the Afghanistan disaster
war in Europe Joe wants you to forget
about all of that that's not what this
midterm is about or he's hoping it won't
be about he wants you to concentrate
instead on hating half the country
hating your neighbor now last week he
kicked off his new political campaign in
front of Independence Hall billed as an
official taxpayer-funded presidential
address with Marines in the background
used as political props and the stage
was lit with an ominous blood red glow
that was so menacing even fake news CNN
was scared by it so they attempted to
alter the color on the Fly you can't
make that up turning it into more of a
hot pink now make no mistake the imagery
was beyond creepy but the speech it was
far worse take a look for yourself
Donald Trump and the Maggie Republicans
represented extremism that threatens the
very foundations of our Republic
ANS do not respect the Constitution
they do not believe in the rule of law
they do not recognize the will of the
people
they refuse to accept the results of a
free election
Mega forces are determined
to take this country backwards
backwards to an America
where there is no right to choose
no right to privacy
no right to contraception no right to
marry who you love
they promote authoritarian leaders and
they fan the Flames of political
violence so let me make sure I have this
straight if you ever question the
results of an election you are a threat
to democracy unless of course you're a
Democrat here's the tape to prove it
I believe he knows he's an illegitimate
president you can run the best campaign
you can even become the nominee
and you can have the election stolen
from you the president is an
illegitimate racist occupying the White
House the Russian uh
weighing in on the election the Russian
attempt to have the election and frankly
the FBI is weighing in on the election I
think make the makes his election
illegitimate he's illegitimate
biggest fear is that he's going to do it
again with the help of Vlad his best pal
and we're going to be stuck for six more
years of this guy and that is terrifying
it's terrifying would you be my vice
presidential candidate
folks look I absolutely agree
that is about the tip of the iceberg
take a look at your screen almost every
major Democrat in America has been an
election denier at some point during
their career it would literally take us
the entire hour to show you every single
instance that we have that we've
chronicled now of course they all get a
pass from the big guy Joe Biden and the
media mob uh even his own press
secretary Kareem Jean-Pierre who is a
frequent election denier herself and a
conspiracy theorist she accused Donald
Trump of stealing the election in 2016
and in 2020 she tweeted quote reminder
Brian Kemp stole the gubernatorial
election from Georgians and Stacy Abrams
but today she told our very own peter
Ducey that it was okay for her to claim
elections were stolen because she had a
really good reason to do it take a look
you tweeted
stole an election I was waiting Peter
when you were going to ask me that
question well here we go you treated
Trump stolen election you tweeted Brian
Kemp stole an election if denying
election results is Extreme now yeah wow
so let's let's be really clear that that
comparison that you made is just
ridiculous I have been I have been well
you're asking me you're asking me a
question let me answer it ridiculous I
was I was talking specifically at that
time of what was happening with voting
rights and the what was in danger of
voting rights that's what I was speaking
to at the time if if Democrats question
election results oh they're not a threat
to democracy they don't care less about
free and fair elections they never
graciously accept election results
themselves and we've got all the
evidence to prove it they don't value
the Republic our constitution our Bill
of Rights they just want power and the
ends will always justify the means to
them it's all about power they want to
fundamentally transform this country as
you are now witnessing so on November
8th here is what is on the ballot in
every state every city every town every
County it's capitalism versus new green
Deal Social realism it's about
individualism versus collectivism it's
about Freedom versus government control
Democrats they want higher taxes
Republicans want to cut taxes Democrats
want more audits 87
000 new IRS agents to harass innocent
American citizens Republicans want less
taxes lower taxes fewer regulations more
freedom more Liberty more money in your
pocket Democrats want climate alarmism
Green New Deal socialism they want to
drive every part of their agenda
Republicans what do they want energy
independence energy dominance so we
could even help our friends in Western
Europe that now are approaching the
highest prices they'll ever pay for
winter heat ever in history all of the
above that's what Republicans support in
terms of energy Democrats they want to
defund dismantle police departments they
want zero bail violent criminals they
allow back on the streets open borders
Sanctuary cities Sanctuary States
Republicans believe in Law and Order and
Safety and Security for every American
and every town in every city they want
our borders secure like they once were
recently they believe in peace through
strength they want classrooms to teach
Reading Writing Math Science History and
computers Republicans also want to
conduct oversight on a federal
bureaucracy that has been weaponized
against millions of Americans make no
mistake it is time for you now it is
after Labor Day The Summer's over to get
engaged get involved get motivated we
will get the country we deserve at the
end of the day this country is not in a
good place by any measure now if the
tiny crowds at recent Biden events as
you can see there wow he's really
getting people out to show up for his
events if there are any indicator
Americans know just who to blame it's
not so-called Maga Republicans this week
again we caught up with a few Trump
supporters they were at a rally that was
packed in Pennsylvania with thousands
outside the arena because there were no
more seats inside and here's what they
had to say about Biden's dark and
ominous rhetoric take a look to quote
Hillary Clinton I think the speech was
deplorable after that despicable speech
by the president with the blood red
background in the Marines threatening
half the country I felt it my duty to be
out here if anybody's a clear and
present danger to democracy it's Joe
Biden that's the only person and the
whole Democratic party I don't listen to
him he's a malt piece that's all he is I
never listen to anything he says it's a
call basically 50 of the country that
type of language I think that's a
shameful absolutely shameful look at gas
prices look at food prices look at
everything that's going on it's not good
so what he's trying to do is demonize
the people that he feels is going to win
and fix things Joe Biden you you've
totally lost it but we all know you're
just a shell you're not even in charge I
can't live with this guy in office
I can't live with him in office anymore
I'm being buried I can't pay my bills I
can't do nothing and I know I'm not the
only one
Americans they are suffering and Joe
Biden simply doesn't care because his
radical left-wing agenda is more
important but tonight there might be one
person even more out of touch than Joe
himself that would be Hillary Clinton
who will never be president is now
inserting herself into the doj and their
latest anti-trump Witch Hunt which was
absent she was absolutely giddy that
Biden's doj raided Trump's home
Mar-A-Lago this is what she tweeted
today quote I can't believe we're still
talking about this but my emails as
Trump's problems continue to mount the
writers trying to make this about me
again there's even a a Clinton standard
the fact is I had zero emails that were
classified all right this needs to be
addressed Hillary is lying but you don't
have to take my word for it listen to
her friend and former FBI director James
Comey
from the group of 30 000 emails returned
to the state department in 2014
110 emails in 52 email chains have been
determined by the owning agency to
contain classified information at the
time they were sent or received
eight of those chains contained
information that was Top Secret at the
time they were sent 36 of those chains
contained secret information at the time
and eight contained confidential
information at the time
although there is evidence of potential
violations of the statutes regarding the
handling of classified information
our judgment is that no reasonable
prosecutor would bring such a case by
the way that does not include the 33 000
emails she deleted with bleach bit or
the devices that she had destroyed with
hammers or the SIM cards that were
removed from the devices she had not
only did Hillary Clinton unlawfully
possess top secret classified material
on her private servers but somehow much
of that material made its way to a
laptop belonging to Anthony Weiner AKA
Carlos Danger who doesn't exactly have
the best track record with keeping
things concealed and secure and secret
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else